bonjour alexandre paulikevitch merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt
france alors vous faites un parti des
trois activistes qui devait être
convoqué hier pour des faits qui
remontent déjà à plusieurs mois qu'est
ce qui vous est reproché exactement en
fait ce qui nous est reproché c'est de
faire face aux forces de l'ordre et de
les insulter
mais au fait c'est ni une question de
ils ont monté d'aidé
des allégations qui sont complètement
fausses c'est juste une question de
vouloir dire aux gens ne vous exprimer
pas ne montrez pas de dissension et
rester calme et je pense que c'est
surtout des tribus des procès pour
vraiment donner l'exemple sur toute
personne qui risque de lever sa voix
alors une cour militaires pour juger des
civils l'action des manifestants est
elle considérée comme une atteinte à la
sécurité de l'état
écoutez il considère beaucoup de choses
une atteinte à la sécurité de l'état et
c'est eux qui décident
qu'est-ce qui veut comment percevoir les
choses
je pense qu'on est dans un délire absolu
et une grave atteinte aux libertés et un
un état qui devient un état policier de
plus en plus et c'est nécessaire de
faire face parce que sinon on va sombrer
dans quelque chose de très noir et on
pourra plus gérer après comment vous
vous prenez personnellement cette
convocation devant le tribunal
militaire on vous imagine forcément
triste d'en arriver là
non pas du tout je suis très énervé très
énervé j'ai perdu ma maison avec le
l'explosion du 4 août
je n'arrive pas à réparer ma maison
parce que les banques ont pris mon
argent et me donne pas on me donne à la
limite de 100 euros par mois 300 euros
par mois et est ce qui vient d'arriver
match c'était la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase pour moi j'ai besoin
d'un peu de dignité gardez nous un peu
de dignité parce que ça devient
inacceptable inadmissible et je suis
énervé je ne suis pas triste
est ce que pour vous cette convocation
est aussi un moyen de vous faire taire
concrètement une tentative je dirais
mais je pense qu'ils sont ils sont pas
ils ont pas imaginer là la solidarité
qu'un artiste peut avoir aucun citoyen
peut avoir quand les choses dépassent
les bornes et c'est au delà d'une
tentative c'est vraiment une politique
de muselage des civils des gens de la
presse de 2,2
des réseaux sociaux beaucoup de gens
vont comparaître devant les tribunaux
interne des tribunaux militaires
à cause d'un tweet ou d'un statut
facebook on est on est dans une dérive
grave
vous parliez tout à l'heure de soutien
vous êtes un artiste on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
est-ce que vous en avez reçu des
soutiens et est ce que au liban on peut
imaginer un mouvement se constituer pour
justement vous vous souvenez vous
soutenir vous et et vous deux autres
camarades
écoutez c'était impressionnant
la solidarité qui a eu que ce soit à
l'intérieur ou à l'international
notamment communiqué de monsieur jack
lang toute la communauté de la danse
contemporaine française a montré du
soutien des grands chorégraphes beaucoup
d'associations lgbt ont montré de la
solidarité énormément de soutien de la
population civile libanaise parce que
aussi j'ai fait beaucoup de presse de
télévision locale c'est si on n'a pas eu
un mouvement qui s'est créée les
tribunaux militaires n'auront pas
reculer et n'auront pas annulé à 7
heures du matin le procès merci beaucoup
alexandre paulikevitch d'avoir répondu
avec nous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions devraient être avec nous par
dont je rappelle que vous êtes danseur
chorégraphe et activiste merci beaucoup